hello hello everyone we are gearing up
to go live with the one and only e so
isn't that exciting
oh no that time is definitely off though
let me get that out of the way let me
edit that was it 147 s of 13 minutes all
right
[Music]
hold on how's everyone doing out there
bt-dubs how we doing out there kiddos
who's just wanted to come in here early
and connect with you check in on you
during this hump day where we are
humping out to q and a's we're doing a
QA with john Heffron excuse me I was
just editing this we're doing a Q&A with
John Heffron at 2:00 p.m. and then a Q&A
with Owen Smith at 4:00 p.m. this is
gonna be a great day
these q and a's just keep getting better
and better oh my gosh what do you say so
thank you everyone tuning in did the
music stop oh yeah it did stop until now
uh good brother how you holding up
Patrick we are hanging in there my man
doing the best we can you know just
trying to survive I see you on the
Facebook's posting funny videos and
stuff keeping your fans happy and
entertained
and still jiving with the Buster cups so
I see you out there buddy it's very good
everything's doing good here we're
really just um staying busy to stay
distracted if you know what I mean
that's really become my strategy is uh
just trying to stay too busy to notice
the world but I want to come in here
early and maybe I'm gonna start doing
these on these q and A's just to come in
and connect with y'all and check in with
you and see how you're doing and what
you're up to so it's very exciting
oh and Patrick says the buster cups are
filming a video oh snap I will
definitely be on the lookout for that
The Lost Tapes of Buster cups the hot
breath that could have been it just
wasn't time yet but what's cool is um we
were talking out going to Jack Harlow
together Patrick and it actually got
rescheduled so there's still time they
actually went ahead and reschedule it to
a bigger venue in Athens so there's
probably still tickets again but
yeah I'm excited to see that buster Cubs
video oh boy oh boy we're getting close
to John Heffron yeah
the lost buster Cubs tape that's right
gonna get my lips ready for the big QA
you guys are watching and have questions
for John go ahead and start posting them
because we're not gonna have much time
with him we're gonna have about we're
gonna have around 30 minutes
John's actually a guest I've been trying
to get on hot breath for a while because
I mean he comes to Atlanta a lot and
I've seen him at the punchline and
connected with him and he's someone I
was never quite able to wrangle in which
is why hold on my dog was
[Music]
alright sorry had to go give my wife the
dog so if you have questions for John go
ahead and post them because we won't
have that much time with them probably
bout 30 minutes he's someone I've been
wanting to get on the show for a while
since seeing him in Atlanta and we're
finally doing it's very exciting
he's just he just released a new book
which another comedian that just
released a new book is Tom Papa and you
best believe I'm gonna shoot my shot on
that so keep in touch since you're
watching this early though breaking news
next week we have Emma Willman Ron
Funches
and Jesse David Fox the host of
Goodwin's podcast probably the number
one comedy interview podcast in the
world except for you know so big week
next week for sure it's very exciting
yeah said Ron Funches yeah here's a new
show coming out on kwibi
so I'm finding if you ask people to do
the show when they have something to
promote they're really likely to do it
so anyway
anybody have court anybody with question
[Music]
two
oh we got a like we got a thumbs up
go back to where to go
oh there's Facebook so yeah those of you
with any questions a lot of you were
like I'm excited to see John so here we
go hello mark how are you doing my
friend
all right kids go onto Skype and get
John with your questions and I'm gonna
go get John and I will be back in a
jiffy
what's better I actually like that
better so I'll be right back kiddos
here's some fun music for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right it's time everybody welcome
back to the hot breath Comedy Network
this is hot breath live comedians on
skype talking comedy and today's guest
is hands-down one of my favorite
comedians out there today and he's soon
to be yours but if you're in for the
live Q&A he is one of your favorites and
if you're watching this on YouTube just
know we do all these live Q&A in our
Facebook groups so if you'd like to join
them in the future
click a link in the description to join
our Facebook group and get that intimate
access to the great comedy minds like
today's guests so without further ado
welcome to the show
the one and only John Heffron ladies and
gentlemen we got him yeah that's what
I've been doing I've just been getting
comics while they're quarantined I'm
like hey right it's kind of an
interesting time so like like I started
a podcast to which I was kind of against
but I did and then I'd reached out to
complex or people you know guess I'm
like there's no way they're gonna do my
thing and boy a lot of people have a lot
of times so it's a good it's a good
content exactly yeah it's so perfect I'm
glad to be here great well the what what
had me reach back out to you because
I've seen you perform in Atlanta several
times and I've always been a fan of your
writing specifically and now that you've
just written your second book actually
the holding deal there it is
go go get this book everyone oh that's a
real book thing it's got a thing with
the thing when you get on your bookshelf
and you're doing Skype calls books right
right right and you have a but yeah it's
got words in there there's page numbers
and then there's little squiggly lines
when it's in between thoughts in case
you get confused it's it's the real deal
it's the holding deal
and I'm intrigued because you call it
like a spy noir but it's basically based
on a comic who gets it seems like
screwed over is this coming from a
personal place here John well the
premise of the book is that there's fake
reality shows on TV that have faked
winners ever watch reality show and
you're like how that person win
well the book is that all these people
put out fake reality shows to get all
these fake winners and then they throw
those winners into like the spy
community because they have an alibi to
travel every week and each one gets
assigned a different thing so in my book
I it's a comic who wins a fake reality
show and he gets asked to be a courier
and every every city goes to he has to
just deliver a package that's it he
doesn't know what's in it
it's all he's got to do is do a show
handing that ve'lo up to somebody after
by the merch table and he gets a few
extra bucks and then the thriller ensues
but you actually won a reality show yeah
we don't know yeah yeah
cuz you want a yes Comic Standing and
they've got a talent deal and that was
kind of the idea how I got it is
everybody at the time this was you know
100 years ago when I was on that show
everyone's like it's faked it was rigged
so you can get a TN literally I won last
Comic Standing and the money I got for
winning I believed when I saw it at the
end of the day was 47 hundred dollars
maybe or something like that you know I
could be off by just a few thing but but
it wasn't you know my season didn't have
money
you didn't win money you didn't win so
what you got was this this holding deal
so after you want it NBC said let's do a
TV show or we're gonna hold you in case
we want to think about maybe kind of
having an idea
that we use you right and that that toll
that show was $50,000 right which it's I
know right now that so it's literally a
doll
so it's $50,000 and everybody on the
show got Union scale for being on the
show if you're with after or sag and
you're on a reality show
I believe it's four dollars and twenty
some sense right so everybody on the
show every time you saw them on TV got
four dollars and in twenty some sense
again I'm messing up the numbers a
little bit here so at the end if you
were from audition show one to a
negative show you made thirty one
thousand dollars over course every year
right so NBC took that my thirty-one
right it subtracted it from the fifty
right wise they subtracted they said
makes about two thirty one 350 right and
then you run it through taxes and all
that but listen I'm not complaining no
no no people on people on that shows
thought that I made like millions and
all this thing they're like it's rigged
on my rigged so somebody can get forty
seven hundred bucks
couldn't you like that just seems like a
lot of work to rig to give somebody
forty seven hundred yeah so that's kind
of like even way back then when you got
some I kind of had the idea for this
book and I'm just a slow writer uh you
know I actually didn't even know how to
write a spy novel like I didn't even
know that was a team so it was a year or
two of me taking you know me like
masterclass like finding all these
online courses yeah of how to actually
structure our novel and I would just sit
my hotel room and get go through the
homework assignment if you know they're
like character development I'd sit there
and I'd go through the modules and it
took me it took me a while and then the
quarantine is the thing that got my
hustle on where I was just bought this
old farmhouse was built like eighteen
forty and you know all your work kind of
just disappeared because everyone's like
yeah nobody's doing a thing and I'm
you're cynical man I got that book on my
hard drive I need to
the spell checker and release that thing
so that's how that book came to be and
getting great response so yeah and you
and this is like a comedy education show
so maybe like what did you learn in the
writing structure and character
development within writing a spy novel
that could translate into comedy writing
a lot of self- talk kind of my brain
like like every time I sit down I would
go I don't I don't know how to write a
spy book I'm not I can't if you know if
you're dating me you'll see my texts are
horrible
I don't know sentence structure you know
I've done stand-up for 33 years I've
never made it I've never done a set list
I never understood like I looked at
people with their notebooks in their in
their setlist and go man I wish I had a
setlist this is this is where all the
cool people are doing I've never had a
setlist I've never I do most of my
writing on stage Oh
so but I mean not to swing background I
kind of have a thing reason why I don't
have a set list um but so when I would
sit down to try write the novel I would
just get in my head going I don't know
what I'm doing this is too hard I should
and then I'm checking Amazon for
crossbows and all that stuff Soho was
very fake it till you make it thing
where I would sit down in we're comics
so you have imaginations you've had a
million play conversations in your head
or in your shower with people and then
that's how what you know [ __ ] turn into
I would sit down and pretend I was a guy
writing a spy thriller I was a character
who write in your spot
I literally separated myself from myself
by one by one thing and I just sat down
and go over to spy writer do and you sit
down and there's like so it was a dark
Sunday and I heard a knock out the door
and I didn't get to in my head of like
well this isn't how John Heffron talked
or whatever so I did that yeah yeah so
that kind of got over that hurdle of
just getting out of my own way you know
and then
there's a lot of fat and a lot of
horribleness and then from there I had
you know chopped it down and then in got
an editor you know to do all some of the
heavy lifting that's so interesting to
hear you don't really you're not pen to
paper and you'll have a set list because
it seems like your material is very
specific and very crafted like word to
word syllable to syllable yeah I wish my
juncture
yeah go go my drunk drawer and go so I
don't go the only time I've ever had to
make a service is anytime you do like a
TV show right anytime you do like a
Tonight Show or at the time I mean I
haven't Comedy Central special from 1990
like those half-hour things that they
did you'd have to write everything out
and those were the hardest shows about I
never did because I've always mind
mapped it and hopefully I'd be able to
show you this
I've already so I always mind acting so
I never I don't know how to set this
joke one two three four five six and
seven because if you have that list in
your on stage and you see the light or
things are going either worse or
whatever in your brain you think I have
to get to ten for my set to be good so
you're not present the entire time
because all you're thinking is I'm on to
I got three minutes left
I gotta get from two to nine in two
minutes and then do my turn as my closer
well I never gave myself a end date I
never gave myself a closer so it's never
I was never in a rush to get anywhere
honey like so I knew I knew what I would
start with um you know because I have
gone on stage without that that beat and
got some I think that's where you get in
the most trouble um you know if you're
kind of clueless right when you you know
me get on stage I never just I never at
a closer and then I would just if I saw
the time was up or I got the light and I
got a laugh I would just say goodbye
so audience doesn't yeah literally if
you just go thank you I'm so-and-so
after any laugh and put your hand up the
audience claps or whatever they have no
meter the they don't get shocked an
electrical shock thing if you didn't
compute your closing bit right all of
that in your head it doesn't matter yeah
say your name and say thank you and
leave nobody make it a hunt and then in
your brain you're like I never got
through the drive-thru mcdonalds bake
yeah nobody knows but you do it next
time
exactly so when your pre-show a lot of
comics are doing a setlist what are what
are you doing - like with your pre-show
ritual I have and I'll show you my mind
now yeah let's go to the mind map right
so when I go on if you go to the mind
map real quick I'll pull it up full
screen - so people can see what so what
I don't care I'll go back to it so what
I do is I always have with with my
stand-up and all my shows I've always
had seams so it's easy for me to
construct an hour so I used to years ago
have a bit about me my family are going
on vacation and we're pulling out of the
driveway and there's all that stuff and
then for an hour I would keep going back
- so we're in the car let me go and then
you stop at this place and then all
these weird herbicides and then we're
bonding it out and then the last bit was
and then we pulled in and it just locked
everything together through the hole so
it's easy for me to bounce around and
I'm kind of only had three jokes my
entire life since I was doing comedy I
literally I had I had I'm getting older
remember when or reminiscing and
relationship okay those are the three
those are the kind of the three things
that I become with you know sprinkle I
always call it just like literally
seasoning right so those are the random
bits and then I would have hours of
material on on both on all those three
things that I said and just with my
watch every 15 minutes I
switch it up so and then some shows I
will gonna start with relationship stuff
and I do really a ship for 15 minutes
and then look at my thing so uh 27
getting old almost 30 and then all this
other comes with that and then remember
this too and then I would just use my
clock just odd and you know even if I'm
crushing it with relationship stuff I'd
be like it's time to move on and I would
just use that so every show was
different because I never started with
joke one and then it was joke ten I
would just play the chords you know
differently so it felt more organic I
think yeah every Chris Rock say the same
thing where he really only talks about
three things and he breaks his show up
into thirds that's it I mean it can be
that for me I'm just inherently a little
bit lazier writer I I can't be all over
in place tis then my brain I have to
have everything connecting I've never
reason why I just brought this up and
you know hey I'm just not
I just hate going solo work what do you
guys want to talk about like I'm not
that there's a reason there's a flow
that that happens and I even sometimes
do shady [ __ ] we're in the beginning of
the show I'll go just like somebody
giving a speech I'll go hey I got three
things I'm excited I'm gonna tell you
guys about wine I'm gonna talk about my
mom but blah blah to ever have this
happen in relationship and then I would
just then I would just start talking
right and we do my whole show and then
at the end of the show like maybe about
five ten minutes before I got offstage I
would look at the crowd and go did I
tell you guys the third thing and
everybody would go no like that whole
time you're waiting for me to say what
number three was but I only cuz I
purposely left out three and that's
called an open loop which I'm a crazy
fan of when you tell somebody you're
gonna give them something and then you
don't and then at the end you give it to
them and then they feel oh I feel
complete that's exactly what we wanted
yeah so just a fine it's just a fun
thing to do doing yeah at least for me
during the show yeah because you have
degrees in communication and psychology
so it sounds like you kind of draw that
as you
into the craft of comedy I think it
makes a big again I'll only speak for me
for me takes stuff fun for me when I
overthink stuff and that all this theory
right you're gonna purist that go no way
man it's a comedy bro you stood up there
you gotta step out in comfort zone all
right man uh I do certain things just to
see if they work for me or if I run I
can run you know joke differently or
even not run it into the ground I wasn't
purposely bomb but you kind of mess with
the chords a little and sometimes the
jokes get bigger laughs then the other
half and sometimes they die a horrible
death even though you're saying the same
words then I say it's kind of like this
horrible example like if you're looking
at a painting at a museum or something
the lighting on that painting makes all
the difference like you can look at this
painting and go that's awesome and then
just turn off a little lights or the
things have shining on it and you're
like oh that's just kind of a move but
it was the lighting that made it so I
think doing that I have a bunch of
techniques I knew when I'm actually
performing that I think adds to it or it
doesn't to be honest with you or it does
nothing but for me if I think it's
working then I guess it yeah you'll do
things like have a spot on stage to try
an older joke there's a new joke and
you'll do anchoring where you're like
connecting words with movements right
you like get into the grit of this well
yeah but every comic does it though um
they just don't know that they're doing
it and then there's a fine line of doing
it on purpose because now you're just
like it's a small word and I'm a trompe
you know it's again it's like come true
you're like using it when there was a
horrible example but using when you want
and they're you know wrong I can name
eight billion comics that have a thing
everybody does when the punchline is
given they do something and it's the
same thing
after every punchline right so you by
the third time the audience know like
subconsciously knows oh that's what
we're supposed to laugh you know it's
like just like that horrible
you know three and a Half Men well after
every joke you know you're kind of doing
the same thing where every time you get
a laugh you move the mic stand down or
you take drink or if you're smoked you
blow out or your shift or you do with
your doing if you do that every time
that they lie you know you can't have it
be something like I kind of get allowed
you know you go yeah like that right
there
they're subtle things that that you can
do that you don't even know you're doing
what are some of the techniques you've
developed over 30 years of doing that
yeah like really you had started to
mention it before about like you have
certain techniques you'll do on stage I
do um I don't know boy it seems like so
long since we've been on stage yeah yeah
I'll do a thing where you know you ever
follow somebody who's just not your
energy or they crush or they eat it in
front of you a lot of people I'll ride
that wave regardless of what they did so
if the act in front of me was pretty
high energy really likable walked around
a lot on stage I'll get on stage and I
will mimic not mimic or imitate but I'll
do that same energy for a couple seconds
and then I'll bring it back to me if
it's not you know the person who kind of
talks slow I talk pretty fast if the
person is just more just this mellow and
just talks like this I'll get on stage
and be like hey guys thanks for coming
out but then then as I start talking
I'll start ramping it up back to me just
did I think people need that that moment
or if somebody was standing a certain
way on stage you're standing in a
certain spot or holding the mic like
this and holding the top of the mic
stand and we're just doing this it's
like no you suck you suck we're much you
know just doing something I'll take the
mic and I'll make sure that I don't
stand this way for a first until that
space is mine
aha just because people are used to
right are useless seeing that if you
were just on stage
I don't even know if you were just going
hey all women should just be pregnant
all women should be pregnant and only
make sandwiches and right ladies what
right I'm just thinking really horrible
things I know then I then I get on stage
right Chuck hey you're still thinking
all that I just said when I gave words
to that so the comic I won't do this
thing I didn't oh we lost John he froze
hold on
he's coming back we're getting him back
John are you there yeah oh no internet
and Oh looks like we're getting motion
again okay I know you're up in your 5x I
don't know if you're off the grid yeah
yeah yeah no I'm the forum house and I
don't have real internet either yeah
yeah cuz you're a doomsday prepper right
like you're really about the life I
bought a old old farm that doesn't have
real cable internet and it's crazy windy
out but we'll be okay if I disappear I
will stand and not take a bandwidth and
we'll be reconnected so that's one
technique I do uh-huh the other stuff I
I enter the stage differently I there's
parts of the stage that I use for
different reasons again this is me just
trying not to be bored and giving me
things to do um you know on stage I used
to run around like some maniac and just
walk back and forth and just just
constantly like I'm trying not to get
hit with anything and then I just got
older and that's just too much work you
know and it's pointless movement so now
I have different places on the stage I
do
different things again more from me than
the audience I think that's what you
mean by anchoring is like to the right
on the right side of the stage I do like
this type of material or this type of
act out and then the middle I do this
and the left I do something else is that
what you mean yeah so if I have I have
the part in front of the mic that's I
throw my ear storm I like matira that I
know works then if I want to try newer
stuff oh I'll kind of maybe move to a
different section like to the stool and
do a lean thing and then I that's where
I try my newer stuff and if that doesn't
go well I'll physically take myself out
of that spot and go back into the heater
spot or if I'm talking to somebody in
the crowd I'll walk over to the table I
got a space kind of just set up for
crowd talk so then when I want that tier
to end I go back and it's again it's a
way for the audiences just know this was
a moment now we're here now we're here
and you can you know you're
subconsciously telling them that stuff
Doha okay so I think this this can tie
into our first question here from
trainer Steve because it's about your
skill as a comedian he asks when did
John first notice his comedic skill
level jump when did you see his largest
spurts and growth and - what does he
attribute those jumps
um one day gross I don't know when the
woman I I think it was like weird
moments like when I would just started
you know back in my day I'm a sound
super old here um seed and then and then
when you got really good as an MC you
were a feature and then when you're
really good as a feature you get you got
to be a headliner right and then but
emceeing was a skill like I'm seeing was
I mean it was a skill kind of a lot of
people don't have now like their hosts
but all they're thinking is my podcast
is pretty good I don't know why I'm not
featuring like they don't know how to
like do not believe how many times I met
clubs if you go can you just can you
just plug this for me or can you just
and they just they're horrible at
announcements and they're saying and you
say something like well I don't normally
I'm okay
but you took the job so don't be a
shitty emcee like it's a whole but so I
somewhere during that when I was that
young like there was a part where I was
like I'm a really good emcee this is a
thing I'm gonna I'm gonna learn my my
minute up welcome to the club the
waitresses are gonna add a hole used
cars men's you know thing I would do in
the first minute on stage and then I
would do a little break take the mic out
no I'm not emcee guy non-comic guy and I
would do the thing and then I put and
bring up a feature so there are parts
there where I I started knowing I'm
stronger than a lot of these features
that I'm working with you know even when
I was a young guy that and then um then
I had a college girl spurt you know
because I was doing maybe 200 colleges
in year this is way back now and NACA
you know era because I was 20-something
you know I was hey what's with roommates
and ramen noodles and blah blah blah
right so there was that and then you
know I think maybe after my first
special I kind of fell oh I have this
dial day you know and weird with my
career I felt like I have some years you
know that I'm like man everything is
tight as
this is this is bulletproof I can walk
up with trying to like this is
bulletproof other years or when you
rearrange stuff for you do an album in
here you're just like yeah this is this
is mediocre I'm it's not you know I'm
hitting the rim a lot and you know
that's still something I don't think you
ever can kind of figure out yeah that
was even like when we had we did one of
these with Nate bargatze and he's like
at the end of every special he
immediately reverts back to I have no
material I'll never be able to write
another joke again what have I done
like there's this self-doubt I feel like
maybe a lot of comics have of like how
could I ever do that again
oh yeah and especially right now
I have two new albums and put out an
album in November or December I forgot
and then even with this whole thing
going on I'm going through one of those
phases where I'm like I don't know what
material I'm gonna talk about once we
start performing again because in my
head already it's like people in front
of me talking about Tiger King and no
for the paper do you mean like exactly
because every comic right so I could do
my experiences in stories would be
different than yours just because we're
different people but now you have
everybody going through the same exact
thing right so it's so you're gonna have
a lot of here's some zoom material that
that's going to be this so that's
already in my head going I'm gonna waste
my time talking about that because a
year from now on Netflix they're give me
seven specials I can tell you the
setlist of those seven specials you know
I'm gonna be zoomed Tiger king I got
pregnant during the thing what you guys
doing court like they there's all these
it's gonna happen you know look how many
videos there are comics making food
right now it's going to be a thing so I
kind of get like locked in my head a
little I'm like yeah I don't think I
have anything anything to talk about
forever yeah then it always comes back
exactly Nate says that after ever have
every special then cranked out another
hilarious one so yeah that's it
here come again all the way yeah so the
next one is from Patrick Fowler says
without a set list
do you write jokes down or do you record
them or do you just keep them all in
your brain I don't write them down I do
do my mindmap thing it's when i first
you know so i'm trying to show you okay
so i like a hundred times a long time
ago i have a bit that's out called when
i get in goobers I lied to the uber
driver right and then I would just write
one too
what's the lie I'm in Phoenix and we
paint lighthouses
okay right and then I start asking
myself a lot of questions about whatever
bit that I wrote down right so why why
would you lie to an uber driver what are
the greatest lies you ever told didn't
did anyone ever think that you actually
did that job what would be like to have
that job do I know anybody who has that
job so now from one question I have a
list like I have a list of things that I
can fill in about that bit then from
there you've kind of built a whole story
and you could go now that I lied at uber
driver bit might have five different
entry points or five different
subcategories so I'm so from thinking
about that I might be like so one time I
told the guy I was a chocolatier and
then that spins off to wonder what's
your training like to be a chocolatier
and edited like you have all these
parallel developments just from that one
idea so that's a new way that I kind of
started right like I used to write
onstage dancer his point I used to write
on stage and then I'd record every show
and then I would pay to have that show
it's like a few bucks just transcribed
I'll take my hour every Saturday I take
Saturday first show right just record it
and then there's a bunch of certain like
you know the service I've used for 10
years but there's a million more you
send it off to them
and three days later you get it all
printed out and then you read your act
so if you did anything new you can kind
of like highlight it or whatever where
you go okay this is you know this is the
new bit and then from there you can kind
of go my dog Jenna barks the rest of
this interview by the way but that's it
well that's how I wrote it down well
yeah that I answer that yeah yes I
answered that question so I used to
write on stage and then I would then I
would transcribe it and only recently
did I start doing that mind mapping
thing because I was on plane and I saw
this guy sketching yeah he would like
sketch a eagle and then he would turn
the like I'm talking he would sketch for
like a minute oh if that he would sketch
for like a minute and then he turned the
page and then it was like a Statue of
Liberty and then he turned the page and
then it was waves and then he'd flip it
back to the eagle and just the whole
flight he was he was burning through
these like four or five pictures
whatever it was and I asked him I go you
don't you didn't spend any time on a
picture like what's your thought process
and he says if he stares at a picture
too long his brain starts relooking at
[ __ ] he drew and what that sucks or he
doesn't know whether you should make the
wings feathery ER or longer so ii his
brain starts questioning what's he's
doing he he blazes over to the next
picture and then he then he deals with
that picture and he just keeps going
back so I went and got a book bought a
notebook and just went to a coffee shop
and literally I lied it'll bird drivers
things I used to stress out about a kid
as a kid what what room in my house do I
hate the most and I was and then I would
go back why would I lie to an uber
driver
I used to stress about reading out loud
as a kid and then before I knew it like
maybe a couple songs and think I looked
I'm like there's three premises here
that all have a thing and maybe it took
me I think I gave myself almost like a
speed round like I did you know I
remember even time I don't
like like one song maybe two songs where
I just started you know going as fast as
I could
and then you were just done so that's
like the new way it's weird I've been
doing comedy like I said for you know
since 87 and it's weird that you have a
new you know it's kind of exciting you
can't have been suddenly a new way of
doing things
yes you just have a night you have an
idea and then asking questions about
that dia almost unearths
the actual punchlines behind it like the
Y like do you have an idea that yeah
like you have an idea that that you're
working on um I think the most recent
one has basing upon theory it's my wife
always has her phone on like 1% and it
kills me okay so okay okay so so what
but so what you would do is you would
write my wife has phone on 1% and then
you would bubble it okay and now we're
gonna ask the building questions why
does she keep why does she run it to the
to the to the very end what else in her
life does she let almost go to the very
end but you know maybe our car should
say on the gas 1% even said a gallon it
should say how many percent from from
right so do you what what when do you
plug yours in at 90 percent
so can a 90 percent or be a saying if
you were on an island would she wait to
like so suddenly we have this whole
story about you and your wife in all it
really is this unit has 1% on her phone
but now we've just taken it now for some
reason you go back to my long rambling
this now I got you and your wife and car
getting gas off of just that her cell
phone chunk right and then you guys are
now were you guys driving to you just
know if she doesn't you know you don't
have gas where were you going
we're going to a why were you going to
age you want to throw axes what date
night ideas do you do now now we went
from your percentage of your phone to an
axe throwing date to
you guys running out of gas two guys
arguing and yous going
I only have 1% left of this in this
argument I think I'm done like so now
we've just told the whole story
that's you know five minutes ten minutes
long by the time you're done and you
have all these in and outs and then you
don't need a setlist because you know
you're gonna do your wife cell phone bit
that's gonna have all these sides and
you know all part of the story oh my
gosh dude I've done over 200 interviews
with comedians and that may be the best
joke breakdown we've been able to
capture on here that was amazing
Wow but I couldn't repeat it cuz I don't
know what I just said no but that's
creativity right you do it in a burst
and you're saying I don't know what
happened but it's there now that was
great
oh we lost John again right when he
gives that tip
I thought that was your mic drop you're
on the iPod here need to make it is that
you don't hang up the phone every once
awhile it starts to fall in your ear
itches that shouldn't be the you know
trapdoor button right there shouldn't be
right there I was wondering I thought I
figured that was just you like all right
and I'm out sexual chocolate yeah
dalla vent and I'm out I mean everyone
seven weeks of comedy school don't like
that was gold right there man Wow so
let's let's do too many listener quit
let's do to these viewer questions and
then we'll get you out of here and back
to your quarantine it's um
yeah and this was something I want to
get into you with was the corporate
world because you're and this may have
been a jump from the Last Comic Standing
start to get you momentum in the
corporate world is that one it made you
yeah people knew who I was
yeah cuz our Last Comic Standing was you
know we're pretty popular season yeah so
yeah in corporate people want people who
are on TV so it definitely helped
yeah and that that corporate money is
real and you've done gigs for like the
FBI and it's like you're you're in the
corporate world so Trent Babb asks what
sort of material uh-huh go ahead no go
ahead I would ask what oh well he was
asking what sort of material are
corporate gigs looking for I've always
done me I'm not well if you know
anything about my stand-up I'm pretty
and I'm not slamming myself but I'm very
vanilla in the sense of I don't push
button I've never forever thought that
you know my opinion or my nasally voice
is gonna change your political thought
or I you know I've never I've always
looked at my comedy as a distraction
sometimes people have really crappy
we need a moment we're just right
somebody talking about play-doh as a kid
right I know it's not edgy and if you do
late night sets you like just okay some
people don't need to hear about you know
how many times you masturbate on your
porn some people don't care right you
would rather just have so I've always
considered myself very matchbox 20 of
comedy nobody hates it nobody loves it
but your vacuum - right so my corporate
things have always been the same is
uh-huh I've always talked about like
relationships or or you know at the time
when I was married I had more marriage
material but it was never in a you know
my my wife or girl you know was never
there horrible for doing this I never
made them sound dumb I've made it very
like very mutual or you know I even
changed it up to your partner and set a
husband wife girlfriend
um so with corporate events the deal is
not especially now is you just you have
to be super super vanilla not stop on
any toast
that's all it was two months ago but you
know what the whole world just blew up
so I don't even know one is if there's
even corporate things going to be a
thing any time soon
you know now I know a lot of comics are
doing like zoom meetings for for
corporate events which just changed it
all up but back to what we were talking
earlier if you're a local guy when this
all comes around it's not talk like
nothing's ever going to be the same it's
gonna be a little weird and there might
be a little thing it's going back to
being a really good host because at the
end of the day most corporate events we
need a host more than they need a
comedian and if you can do both if
you're really good at you know bringing
up the vice president of marketing and
you just know how to move things along
and throw in a couple little bits before
you bring up you're gonna get a hundred
times more work than then expecting to
go out and do a half hour what people
are eating dessert you know
you market yourself as I can host your
dinner event and make it entertaining
and move it along you make more money
like there'll be more jobs for you yes
or just get really good at zoom meetings
and you might even crush it even more I
don't know
everything I'm telling you apply two
months ago yeah most of my corporate
work has come from like either
word-of-mouth or like a gig salad
service or something like that what have
you found to be the best way to book
corporate work I you know I have great
agents in man it's you know my hustle
yeah my hustle you know I haven't had
the really building relationships with
you know that so that I can't speak to
you know for me it's just I get a phone
call and they're like hey you you want
to go off and do this and I go yeah so
so was that was that an agent who booked
the FBI for you is that how that goes
down yeah my agents that you - yeah like
I get you know in what where most of my
corporate bookings come from is the
relationship between the people putting
on the event not necessarily the
corporation because what happens is
Corporation a again this is prior to two
months ago and who knows what's
happening but because they'll say we're
doing an event it's at this resort we
need dinner dancing breakout sessions
and an entertainer then that person who
they hired the event person goes okay
I've worked with this comic before I've
worked with Nate Bhagat and then this
show usually the clients a couple comics
and they pay so there's been a couple
corporate people who I've just never
been an ass like in my group my writer
you know like stuff you need before show
9 I think doesn't have anything so I'm
less of a pain cuz I always figure I'm
making enough money where if I want beef
jerky or 5-hour energy I'll go to
7-eleven after the show by myself and
not make this person who's putting on
this huge multi-million dollar event
have to worry about me and I've gotten
rebooked just because I'm not a pain in
the ass I literally come sit on the
speaker box and then somebody goes okay
you're going on stage I go thank you
walk out there and I do it and then I go
goodbye everybody
and then I leave it's been my play be a
good co-worker yeah that goes a long way
in this game so this can go into our
final here with Mark Mitchell who asks I
started out at 62 and your experience do
twenty to forty year olds laugh at older
people 22 forever you know I'm
officially kind of one of those older
people you know in crowd but it's kind
of yes if you don't crap on them I see a
lot of like I I'm so anti-prom ado
Millennials you sound like an old
crotchety guy and they're gonna okay
boomer yeah there's a way you can talk
to younger people if that's what you
want to do there's a way you can do it
and not be an ass I can name you know
look how many comics are gonna be in the
mid-50s if not even 60s every famous gut
you know comic you kind of know right
now is all entering that silver era like
every top guy you can think of it's
probably over 50 so if you're 60
something you're not that far off you
know if you talk about I had to go get
my you know to the proctologist you know
if you talk about old person's stuff
then then you're gonna lose that 20 or
30 year old but you know George Carlin
was however old he was younger people
liked him as long as you don't get too
specific you'd be like don't you hate it
at the sock hop when you're playing your
records in the malt shaker
breaks then the 20 year olds aren't
gonna know what you're talking about but
right now with everything going on if
you're 62 or 22 you both of you are
going through the same exact thing right
now
so there's your common denominator and
everybody's gonna have that so it's a
it's kind of night not not it's not nice
nothing that's going on is life but it
is a reset where now the whole world has
one thing that everybody went through
there's not a person on earth you can't
do a joke about putting it haven't wear
masks everything you got whatever
whoa in the world people were like yeah
we exactly yes it's almost like you
saying
sharing your point of view regardless on
what it is will get you further and
connect with more audiences than if
you're trying to be super specific like
you know the sock hop and the record
player it's more like giving your point
of view on something and then audience
will be attracted but it but if you will
yeah but if you wanted you almost have
to ask you something what you wanted
like its own itchy now write down you
know the gentleman who asked you that
question if if he's 62 so he's 12 years
right he's from his musical reference
would even be different than mine
because he's 12 years so maybe you don't
want to talk to 20 year olds right like
there's something to be said you don't
you could be get older as a comic and
not have to do shots in front of
everybody you go I smoke weed you guys
smoke weed I'm cool too right to get
like you cannot you know you can get
older and not do that the 20 year olds
might not think you're funny but do you
care if they do it you're trying to jump
you're tick-tock numbers right or do you
write your set there's a huge industry
for for you know retired people all over
that have these theaters that are you
know there's retirement communities of
thousands of people it's well again
prior to three weeks ago three months
ago yeah but would show up so that
there's a there's a huge lane for you
know talking about you know going to see
right or whatever yeah you related to as
a teenager there's still a lot of people
that age that are your age that will get
that material speak to them I don't you
know I mean like them yeah who cares
what they did 20-something you know
forty years younger than you unless
that's your thing
exactly there's also you can make a case
that you don't need to boom awesome well
dude Jon Heffron this has been gold
thank you so much for doing this I hope
perfect
I hope you had a good quarantine and
staying safe in closing with your 30
years of experience and the book the
holding deal which we will link the link
has Amazon link in the show notes as
well as the description of this YouTube
page but in the 30 years you've been
doing comedy do you have any favorite
comedy advice or anything you can leave
us with to keep us young comics out
there producing the best comedy we can
young kind felt like my thing I don't
know if I'm what advice I have things
that just bugged me that yeah I don't
even know again with everything going on
I don't know if it's a thing anymore
it's weird I wish I had so much advice
but like specifically now I'm just
telling myself just to shut up because
Who am I to you know it's almost like
somebody from the 80s you know an 80s
band telling you know a new a new band
how you play the synthesizer it's you
know you everyone figure it out how
about it don't don't have your your
roommate come in the green room and take
the headliners charger cord off of his
phone and plug it in bad advice it's a
good start
okay I think that is a thing yeah all
right and mark saying Thank You Trent
saying thank you very much big fan so
you made a big big impact on us today
for sure so taking time out of your day
John and I will be sure to push that
link to your book go get his book this
guy is a comedy guru who is now author
two-time author so thank you John for
all your wisdom today buddy all right
everyone
[Music]